ننتقل الان الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وتطوراتها الميدانيه حيث اعلن رئيس شركه
فاقنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه يفجين
بريجوجين عن سيطره قوته بشكل كامل على شرق
مدينه
وقال بريجوجين على حسابه الرسمي في
تيليجرام ان كل المنطقه الشرقيه من
المدينه الواقعه شرق نهر ضخمودكا اصبحت
تحت سيطره قوته بشكل كامل لكن القوه
الاوكرانيه قالت ان جنودها ما زالوا
صامدين في المدينه
ويدافعون عنها ميدانيا ناقلت قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها تصدت لاكثر
من مئه هجمه على مختلف المحاور لا سيما في
باخموت ولمان
واكدت انها نفذت سبع غارات على مواقع
تمركز للقوات الروسيه ودمرت نظاما مضادا
للطائرات وثلاثه مستودعات وقود واسقطت
مسيره من نوع اورلان من جهه ثانيه قالت
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
من القوات الروسيه نفذت 24 غاره واطلقت
صاروخا بعيدا المدى اليوم تحديدا معنى من
موسكو مراسله الجزيره ايمن الزبير ومنكياف
مراسله الجزيره حسن الشوبكي البدايه مع
حسن الشوبكي
وما الذي تفصح عنه القياده الاوكرانيه
بشان الوضع في بخموت مع اعلان يافقيني
بريكوجين عن السيطره على
شرق باخمت بالكامل من قبل قوات فاجنر
نعم حسن يعني القياده الاوكرانيه العسكريه
تحديدا قدمت بيانات بهذا المعنى في الصباح
وقالت ان هنالك اكثر من 30 هجمه تم
تنفيذها باتجاهها يعني بلدات بالخوفكم
ودبوبه
وايضا العديد من البلدات ولكن وصلت بهذه
الهجمات الصاروخيه وكذلك الهجمات بانظمه
جراد
بانها والمدفعيه وصفتها بانها يعني
محاولات فاشله معهد دراسه الحرب البريطاني
اكد صباح اليوم ان هنالك القوات الدفاع
الاوكرانيه تشن ايضا هجمات باتجاه غرب
باخمت وهذه الهجمات يعني المحاوله فيها
للحفاظ على الطريق بطريقه امدادات الذخيره
والمؤن بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
المتواجده هناك فيما يتعلق بالوضع بباخ مت
كما اورد الرئيس زلنسكي قال ان يعني اذا
روسيا القوات الروسيه تقدمت اكثر يمكن ان
تفتح الشهيه لها لطريق ابعد تبعد مثلا
حوالي 35 كيلو مترا عن غرب اخ مت وهذا
ممكن ان يساعدها لان تفتح طرقا اكثر وتتجه
باتجاه محاور جديده لكن
العمليات في باقمه مستمره وكما اكد
المتحدث باسم القياده الشرقيه
للجيش الاوكراني للجزيره قال واكد ان
الصمود الاوكرانيين والقوات الاوكرانيه
هناك مازال قائما حسن على صعيد اخر وصعيد
هذا سياسي
انطونيش الامين العام الامم المتحده سيبحث
اليوم مع الرئيس في العاصمه كييف مساله
اتفاق الحبوب
وهنالك مطالب اوكرانيه بتمديد اتفاق لمده
عام طبعا هذا الات تنتهي في السابع عشر من
الشهر الجالي وهنالك مطالب بان ينضم ميناء
للتصدير بالاضافه الى الدعم العسكري واختم
بذلك الدعم العسكري هنالك لقاء بين زالوج
زلوج القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بالامس هذا اللقاء على درجه
كبيره من الاهميه مع القائد الاعلى لقياده
قوات حلف شمال الاطلسي الجهراء كابولي
الامريكي وهنالك كلام عن دعم عسكري متواصل
لاوكرانيا حسنا ننتقل الى موسكو مع ايمن
الزبير لنرصد الروايه الروسيه في هذا
الملف
نعم ازدهار بالامس القوات المواليه لموسكو
كانت تتحدث عن سيطرتها على تقريبا خمسين
في المئه من مدينه باخموت وايضا ميليشيا
فاجنر كانت قد تتحدثت عن تواجد ما بين
12.20 الف من القوات الاوكرانيه اليوم كما
اشار مؤسس ميليشيا فاجنر
تمت السيطره على المنطقه الشرقيه من
المدينه وقبل قليل
ظهر بريجوجن في فيديو في قلب مدينه
فيها نوع من الاستفزاز قال انه سعيد بقرار
الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلينسكي القاضي بمواصله القتال
لكنه طلبه بالكف او التوقف عن ارسال من
وصفهم بالفتيان وكبار السن في هذا الفيديو
ايضا تحدث عن مالات هذه وما بعد هذه
المعركه قال ان دور فاغنير قد يتحدد بعد
السيطره على بخموت وتحدث ايضا عن ما جاء
في تصريحات وزير الدفاع الروسي الذي قال
انه بعد السيطره على مدينه سيتم التقدم
الى عمق الدفاع
الاوكراني وبالتالي قال ان العالم سيشاهد
قوه الجيش الروسي قوته العملياتيه على
صعيد ايضا الاستخبارات وايضا المعدات هذا
في شق بخموت لكن الى جانب هذه التطورات
تتواصل ارتدادات التسريبات الصحفيه التي
تتحدث عن الجهه التي نفذت عمليه تخريب
خطاي نورسريم هناك قناعه مفردها في روسيا
ان هذه
الاعتداءات نفتدتها دول الغربيه وبالتالي
هذه التسريبات لم تغير الموقف الروسي
الناطق باسم الكريملين طلب الجهات
المتضرره الدول المتضرره من هذا من هذه
التفجيرات بفتح التحقيق ايضا قال ان هذه
التسريبات تهدف الى تشتيت الانتباه وهو
نفس التصريح الذي جاء على لسان الناطقه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه التي قالت انه
سيتوجب ايضا دراسه التسريب الاول الذي كان
قد نشره الصحفي الامريكي سيمر والذي اشار
الى تورط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه شكرا
لك من ماسكا مراسله الجزيره ايضا الزبير
نشكر ايضا مراسل الجزيره حسن الشوبكي كان
معنا منكيف